Speaker 1: The David Pakman Show, of course,
continues to be a community supported program.
That means you you are part of the community,
at least in my book.
You are you can sign up at join Packman dot
com.
We provide quite a suite of member benefits
for our paid subscribers, including the Daily
Bonus Show.
In addition to the daily podcast, commercial
free audio and video streams of the show.
Every day you get them hours before everybody
else.
Invitations to the members only town halls
and most recently a new member benefit, which
is that you get access to an equivalent of
my soundboard album.
Now the soundboard from which I play all those
exciting clips we have made that a member
benefit as well.
Join Pack com is the place to sign up.
Okay, let's speak to the audience.
Welcome.
You can speak to me at David Pakman dot com
slash discord very easy You join the waiting
lobby and you raise your hand and we are going
to start today with oh I don't know how about
Mark from Los Angeles.
Mark from Los Angeles, welcome to the program.
What is on your mind today?
I am thrilled to have you with us.
A boy, Mark from Los Angeles.
I've invited you on, but you've got to accept
or it is going to go, baby.
And there is Mark from Los Angeles.
Losing the opportunity.
That's really too bad.
Let's try Jack from Connecticut.
Jack from Connecticut.
What's going on, my friend?
All right.
Jack from Connecticut has accepted the invitation,
but has the wrong audio device selected?
Speaker 2: Oh, fantastic.
Speaker 1: Welcome, Jack.
Now I can hear you.
Speaker 2: Okay, Fantastic.
You can hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right.
Well, good afternoon, David.
Thank you very much.
I mean, again, a pleasure.
I wanted to bring I wanted to bring up an
interesting topic that's happening in about
two days time.
Okay.
So in two days time, the Republican National
Committee will select will have its leadership
election.
And for the first time in about ten years,
there will be more than one candidate.
Those candidates are incumbent Ronna McDaniel,
Mike Lindell, unfortunately, and the former
national committeewoman for California.
And I just wanted to know if you've been following
the story and if you had any thoughts to share.
Speaker 1: Well, I support pillow in this
race.
I have absolutely no stake whatsoever and
no involvement in Republican Party politics.
But it just seems to me that Mike Pillow being
RNC chair would be the most humiliating thing
to the Republican Party.
So that's what I'm in favor of now.
I couldn't tell you, Jack, because I haven't
been following it.
Whether Pillow has any shot whatsoever, like
from what you know.
Could he end up being RNC chair?
Speaker 2: I mean, given the fact that we
all know the deep division that is running
rampant in the Republican Party.
Yeah, I my my personal guess is either McDaniel
or Mike Lindell, honestly, at this point,
because realistically, I don't think the national
conference will select a committeewoman from
a deep blue state.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: Interesting.
Well, we are going to see, I hope it's pillow
just for the memes and the lulls.
And I know that that's a very inappropriate
way to analyze it, but it's like, I hope they
destroy themselves, you know?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
It's honestly something that the Republican
Party needs to realize and wake up to, because
if they really want to re reshape themselves,
if they even had an image in the first place,
they really need to think about things like
they ever would.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Pillow as your RNC chair is not exactly a
signal that you're sort of serious that you're
taking seriously the destruction that MAGA
has done to your party.
Speaker 2: Yeah, exactly.
But it was just it was just an interesting
topic that I wanted to bring up and thank
you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Jack from Connecticut, We will watch the election
results very, very closely.
Let's go to Ty from Iowa.
Ty from Iowa.
Welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David.
This is my second time calling in.
Speaker 1: All right, well, let's make sure
it's not the last.
Okay.
Speaker 2: All right.
So I just wanted to ask, do you think it's
kind of weird that that so many people kind
of list with countries like China or North
Korea as communists when they really don't
fit the what is it like the.
Speaker 1: The definition they.
Speaker 2: Would have to be a the definition.
They would have to be like, you know, a country
of no class money or state, you know, all
that stuff.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, I don't know that I agree with you
completely in the sense that communist and
socialist countries, it's it's not uncommon
that it's sort of like communistic or socialistic
for most people.
But then through corruption and cronyism,
there actually is an upper class that that
I don't think that alone makes it not actually
communist or socialist.
But, you know, for me it's less about is North
Korea actually communist than focusing in
on the specific human rights abuses and and
just completely insane familial passing of
power that exists.
Yeah I don't concern myself much with whether
they really meet this or that.
It's sort of like when you do the Jordan Peterson
stuff where you try to criticize something
that Jordan Peterson said and someone will
come out and say, no, you're not completely
accurately criticizing what he really said,
you're criticizing something else.
It's of like, well, you shouldn't really criticize
this as a communist country because here's
a way in which it's not really communist.
I don't know.
I don't get too involved in that, really.
Speaker 2: Okay.
I understand that.
I think people should just realize that, look,
I mean, there are people on the left that
can be bad and people on the right that can
be bad, you know?
And I just.
But I don't know, I just kind of if you really
kind of look into it.
Some people have argued that North Korea would
actually be influenced by like Japanese fascism
instead of something like, I don't know, like.
Speaker 1: Much like modern communism.
Yeah.
Listen, I it's it's mostly moot because I
think for me, it's.
Let's identify the things that are not going
well and let's see if we can improve on them
for the benefit of the people.
And there are many of those things in North
Korea, that's for sure.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that makes sense.
Speaker 1: All right.
Ty from Iowa, thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: All right.
Thank you for talking to you again.
Pleasure.